[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the dave the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life
and your money my name is anthony
o'neill host of the popular youtube
and podcast show the table with anthony
o'neil and
co-hosting with me uh today is the
national syndicated host ken coleman
uh the host of the ken coleman show the
number one career show
in the world and today we are really
excited to be talking with you here
on the ramsay show because we're going
to talk about your life
your money your careers how to
land your dream job and then once you
get the dream job
i'ma show you how to get some more money
pay off some debt
and build wealth yeah that's how it
works that is you know
you want to make more money let's get
you a better job people ask all the time
on the ken coleman show because they
know i'm a part of ramsey solutions hey
ken
can i change jobs while i'm in the baby
steps and the answer is yes because i do
not prescribe that anybody jump off
of a mountaintop we you know we're just
going to take a big risk no no no
no that's not necessary and some of you
out there uh
are feeling like you know what you want
to do but you don't know how to get
there
uh we'll take your calls on that today
i'll give you a very very clear path on
how to get there
some of you know what you want to do how
to get there but maybe you got some
family holding you back you got some
money problems holding you back that's
where ao comes in and we'll work through
that
and get you on a plan and when you get
your money plan going
well then you can actually move towards
that dream job a whole lot
faster so we're taking your calls all
across the board about your life we're
really excited so what are you waiting
on i think i think somebody out there
right now been listening they're going
all right
i'm i'm gonna call i'm gonna trust these
guys and if you are
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two
five five two two five uh ken coleman
anthony o'neil we are here to take your
phone calls and we're gonna go out to
uh boston and i love uh boston because
we have terry out there terry good
afternoon how can ken and i help
hey hello thank you both for taking my
call yeah
my question today is regarding
purchasing a used car
i've been following the steps and we're
on
four five and six and i'm you know i
need a new car
but i'm not gonna buy a new car so my
question is um
when purchasing a used car do you
recommend
certified pre-owned versus just
pre-owned
that's one do i buy a warranty on these
things
if i were to do it and if i pay cash
typically do the dealers negotiate
when purchasing used cars uh man tara
this is such a great question because
i'm actually in the middle of this
literally right now um i totaled my
vehicle
uh back on uh february 14th actually
valentine's day
and so i am in the process of doing that
but here's the very
first thing terry that i want to ask you
what's your budget
so i i'm not worried about a warranty
i'm not worried about cpo a certified
pre-owned car
uh what is what's your actual budget
that's what you need to ask yourself
right well presuming i get about four
for my current car
i would pay a total of 18. okay um so
that would be like 14 of my own
cool you know plus for trading so that's
that's your budget you have 14 000
cash plus your budget then the next
question you gotta ask yourself is
what's your ideal car then once you
identify that ideal car
you're gonna do some research around
that car okay
uh what's the maintenance on the car how
many miles do they tend to start having
um
issues you're not really looking at okay
hey i want to get a warranty i want to
get a cpo there's nothing wrong with
getting a certified pre-owned vehicle
don't get me wrong with that part
but the very first question is budget
your ideal car
do the research and to and then from
there determine the car's value
if you're getting a honda if you're
getting a nissan or toyota
i mean those cars are reliable you don't
you don't need a warranty on those kind
of cars
um so i would not be concerned about a
warranty because here's the truth
they're going to charge you four grand
for a warranty that only costs them 500
yeah you know so i wouldn't do it can
you have any ideas i would just add one
thing i thought would you say is
absolutely spot on i would say that uh
any reputable
uh seller of a car whether that be a
dealer a used dealer or a
person in the marketplace a direct
seller tell them you want your mechanic
to check it out
yes and so you can provide something to
them where they know you're not going to
steal the car they know how to find you
and i would take the car and get it
checked out that would be the only thing
from a warranty standpoint it's not a
true warranty but hey
i'm going to have my mechanic look this
car over and go this is the shape it's
in
a mechanic on a car like that adds to
the research that ao told you to do
which is
you know hey how do these cars do i'm
not going to mention any answer there
are certain cars that are
very nice premium cars oh yeah that once
they get to about a hundred thousand
miles
it's just a problem waiting to happen
absolutely can you hit that
dead on and i'm actually having the car
that i'm looking at purchasing you got a
guy looking at it yeah i had the actual
dealer looking at it okay you know so
that's one thing if you don't have a
mechanic hey
take it over to the dealer uh give them
100 bucks and they'll do a certified
uh pre-owned pre-inspection where
they'll go through it
like they'll buy the cell in their car
lot and they'll let you know hey here
are the here are the issues
but these are not major issues so do the
research but the key thing here though
is
america you set your own budget when you
set your budget
if it's fifteen thousand dollars then
find your ideal car within the budget do
not do hey i want
this car and then will will it fit in
this budget and if it doesn't then you
up your budget do not do that so that's
the very first thing i would say
i'm going out uh to new york city's have
a conversation with uh danielle
good afternoon good afternoon
um i have a it's a little bit complex
question but hopefully you guys can help
me out
yeah um i um
so i i have a great job i have i work
for the state of new york
and um but as everybody knows new york
is a very expensive
state i pay a lot of taxes my mortgage
my mortgage isn't what i owe my house is
not that much
but the taxes just kill me now
uh my wife i have married i have three
kids
um i make about 75 000 a year my wife
works part-time
and stay-at-home mom time also
but we we are in baby step two i had i
saved my thousand dollars
and um i just have so much debt not so
much debt but i owe about
twelve thousand dollars in credit card i
have a pension loan is about five
000 and my wife has a student loan
that's 20 000.
now the issue i'm having is because my
mortgage and the taxes
my i'm pretty much house poor my money
goes
all in what my house is my bills
my utilities now there's an opportunity
where
my grandfather i could buy his house for
really low price in florida but it
consists of
me starting over and um
i don't know that's it's not a right
away kind of thing but it's more of a
future thing
is that something i should do or
consider doing
i don't know well i think you have to
consider it because of the financial
opportunity but you only consider
it as that okay if we move to florida
our housing all of a sudden gets
way way way more affordable but what do
you want to do with your life what work
you want to do do you like the work
you're in you know you have to look at
the whole picture
how's your wife feel about it the kids
are probably young enough they don't
care
it doesn't really matter but i think
since that's a long-term opportunity
anthony i think daniel what you've got
to do is we've got to figure out how to
get your housing situation
better right now this florida thing is
not something that's happening anytime
soon
so in order for you to get out of these
baby steps a little bit faster
let's look at how we can sell that home
and maybe sacrifice our living
uh to have a much cheaper living
arrangement now
to make progress for the future
absolutely man and sorry for going
danielle man moving too quick daniel
i own that one man hey this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show and jack is with
us in new orleans good afternoon jack
how can
ken and i help hey thanks for taking my
call y'all
yeah i am
wondering about how to help support my
mother
she doesn't need it right now but she
doesn't have enough saved up to retire
when she wants to and uh i have uh
the opportunity to make either a lot of
money
uh in my future career or less money
the trouble is a lot of money is going
to come with a lot more work
and not necessarily in the doing the
kinds of things that i necessarily
really love doing and i'm just trying to
figure out how to prioritize that
so are you asking that question as if uh
which decision do i make which is best
for me or best for my mom sounds like
that's how you're asking that am i
understanding that correctly
um yeah i mean i i'm trying to thread
the needle here i want to do
both i guess no i don't think so i mean
you you
i know you want to help your mom but you
don't want to take that career path
that makes a lot of money but has a lot
of other sacrifices
correct yeah yeah you'd be right about
that the only reason you're even
considering is because you think it'll
put you in a position to help your mom
play catch-up
correct well well i mean it would be
nice i got
about 40 000 in student loan debt and
the benefit of that would be that i
wanted that i pay it off quicker
right and you know that's nice uh but i
i'm pretty decent you know i'm pretty
decent at budgeting and saving money and
and so i i don't need to do that i don't
think so my point is i'm trying to help
you hear how you sounded because the
answer to that is no
i'm never going to recommend somebody
and ao wouldn't either
to to go to work in a career go pursue
something
that is going to cause all kinds of
other long-term
sacrifices that are not necessary to be
made you don't have to make those kind
of
i don't like it it's not something i do
but i'm just doing it
to uh make more money and help mom out
so so
that that needs to come off the table
now how to help mom
you know to sit down with her uh i'll
let ao take that one but i mean
this is this is sitting down with mom
and going hey mom we got to start to
take this really seriously
and where do you want to be what is that
what do you want that to look like
i tell you what i do first i'd have her
go to chris hogan's website
chrishogan360.com
and i would do the retire inspired
calculator just to get some real numbers
it's a really wonderful tool
and then then you then she knows what
she's dealing with but reality and
clarity is what we need right now with
mom
but i don't think you know the outside
of helping mom with a plan
helping mom with a goal but you to make
a professional decision
even in small part to help mom that's
not on you brother that's not on you
yeah i agree how old is your mom
she's uh 55. 55. okay cool and she has
no savings at all
she has about a hundred in retirement
a hundred okay so she has about a
hundred thousand dollars in retirement
and
um anything else does she have does she
have any debt right now
uh her house she's got about 100 left on
the house 100 left in the house 100 000
in retirement okay and then any kind of
income coming in right now
she currently works she's a she's a
nurse uh but
she she works in like a high intensity
kind of nursing
and she's she's already talking about
how much strain has taken on her working
so hard and so
i have a feeling that she's going to
step down into a lower paying position
soon cool well jack i want to i want to
tell you man
i appreciate your heart as a son i can
tell that you love your mother
i can tell that you want the best for
your mother um
i want to echo what ken said i totally
100 agree with him
but i think now is the time you just
start you got to have a real good
conversation with your mom
i would definitely say you know take
your mom out to a nice dinner man and
you pay for it
i say mom let's dream here where are we
going in the future i'm concerned
i love you i want the very best for you
um but
how can we set you up to win so this
doesn't impact me and my family
down the road but how do we start making
decisions now that impact your tomorrow
that impacts your retirement
that impacts your future all of our
futures and just walk through the steps
with your mom
definitely get her uh plugged into our
colleague here
chris hogan have her go to
chrishogan360.com walk her through her
walk her through the retirement
calculator and just start figuring out
what can we do to start setting her up
to win
uh but how you help your mom is just by
having the conversation
not by putting more stress on to you and
your
you and your family personal family and
so that's what i definitely recommend
but
i appreciate your heart my brother um
and i believe god is going to bless you
for your heart
uh but just have the conversation man
all right i appreciate y'all hey no
problem at all no problem at all
man uh brad is with us in wisconsin brad
good afternoon how can
we help question isn't for me guys well
first of all thanks for taking my call
this is for our 19 year old son he was
homeschooled
through high school about a 30 on his
a.c.t
loves god volunteers at church
and he decided to take his first year
after high school to work
and true to his word he has been working
like a dog
and he's doing very well at work but he
doesn't know what he wants to do
he is self-taught in graphics he built
his own
piece he was oh we lost him boy we're
getting to the gym i know it was it was
it was getting good man
oh boy it was okay we're gonna try to
get him back
we're gonna be trying so let's set this
up while we try to get him back so
here's a dad
whose son very bright yeah says dad i
want to take a gap year
and i'm gonna work and he has so he's
busting it
right and so he's like but he doesn't
know what he wants to do well 19 year
olds have
limited life experience true sure so
what do we want to do as parents we
don't want to get concerned about that
because we got a kid who's
very intelligent probably done very well
in school has been working he said like
a dog
and working hard yeah uh and so that
puts him in a situation where we've got
a character
kid we got a kid who's got good
character yeah so what do we want to do
we want to go in and get some themes and
i'm going to see if we can get this from
dad when we get him on the line
we want to get some themes of the type
of work and we already started to hear
it he's self-taught with graphics
and right before he got disconnected he
said he likes to build
and so it sounds like to me we got a kid
who ao with his head
and with his hands yeah he likes to be
active and creative in some form or
fashion so what we want to do parents
is we want to look for the themes that
we've been watching these kids
uh with their whole life what are the
themes what do we see where they
they're really really good at something
ao they they naturally are gifted
uh other kids or maybe even another kid
in the home struggles with one issue or
one topic
and this kid excels that's the talent
piece
and then what makes their heart get real
excited when they're engaged in it
that's the
passion piece and the last piece is what
do they want to produce in the world
what result do they want to put out here
in the world
that makes them feel like i have done
something that matters deeply to me
because i see a direct result of my work
that's mission talent passion mission so
the way that works ao
a purpose sentence for anybody parents
out there looking to start this
conversation with a kid
here's what it looks like you were
created to use what you do best that's
your talent
to perform work that you love to do
that's passion
to accomplish results that matter deeply
to you that's
mission yes that's your purpose now you
can fill in the details
for ao it's a little bit different for
me right but
that's how we begin to see this and for
a 19 year old when you when you got a
kid you're going oh they just don't know
what they want to do yet well
they have a pretty decent idea you just
got to be okay
digging yeah you were a youth pastor for
years you've had these conversations
with parents and kids
absolutely but ken i i'm gonna ask you
this question he was a smart kid
very smart how come he didn't go to
college i suspect
i suspect because i wish dad was on the
line we're gonna try to get him online i
suspect it's one of two things maybe
both
one the kid kind of knows i'm not sure
that traditional college is the best way
to get where i want to go
right but that's a that's almost taboo
to a lot of families yes
for a kid to even say that and then the
second reason is
is uh i think he's wondering deep down
yeah what he really wants to do he's
trying to figure it out it's one of both
so he's going i actually just want to
take a year because he may be
this kid who goes i just want to see
what it is before i commit to something
else he could be
that mature it's not crazy to think that
he could be that mature to go
i'm not sure yet so i'm going to work a
little bit save up some money and maybe
he's read debt free degree
am i right there's a third reason why he
didn't go
i wish we could take a poll right now if
your kid was this smart
um i want y'all to answer this out loud
why are you driving in your cars while
you're watching this on youtube
if your son or daughter was smart and
they came to you and said mom dad
i don't want to go to school i want to
go work would you tell them no you're
going to school
or you're working when we come back we
may talk about that a little bit more
hey i love this one we got to get him
back on the line kelly
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
ramsey show
the one and only national syndicated
host uh the number one career radio show
in the world
and i mean that i know my producer is
saying in the world yeah you can listen
to him on podcast can call me
and uh my name is anthony host of the
popular youtube show the table with
anthony o'neil and before
actually not right before the break but
on our last segment uh
brad was on the line and he was raving
about his son and just
speaking highly of him and unfortunately
we got disconnected so
uh brad we want to come back to you and
we really want to
finish this conversation because it
sound like you have a sharp young man
and we want to help you out however we
can so go ahead and finish what you
started before
we got disconnected yeah well hope this
one works better
thanks for calling me back yeah uh yeah
our son mike our son micah is an amazing
young man
he's always been able to have
conversations with adults
he was homeschooled by his mom as are
his two brothers
all the way through k through 12. he is
self-taught graphic artist he has done
some graphics for his youth group at
church
he assembled his own computer at 16. an
avid reader
loves to work out and at his job
they tried to make him a manager at 16
but had to wait until he was 17
because that was their policy and he
just doesn't know what he wants to do
he knows he doesn't want to take on a
bunch of student debt
chasing a degree he may or may not want
at this time
and he's got like twenty thousand
dollars saved up um
my my wife and i are everyday
millionaires we both grew up without any
spoons in our mouths whatsoever
just hard work and getting after it and
it hurts me to see him not have any
direction
i i know if he went to a university in
the people's republic
of wisconsin he would get in trouble
because he's very opinionated very
conservative
and loves the lord and i
i don't think it would go well for him
so okay guys given that
what would you tell this kid well first
of all i want to talk to you before i
tell you what to tell him i want to tell
you dad you need to relax
yeah i mean i'm serious you're a good
man
but you need to relax you got yourself a
rock star in the waiting
and you're you're hurt he is i know but
you can't
like on one hand you just gave us this
glowing resume of your son and
and i believe it but on the other hand
you're like well it just hurts that he
doesn't know what he wants he's 19
and he's a kid who knows enough to say i
don't want to commit to college
and and go into some type of financial
situation
that is not sustainable long-term he
doesn't want to go into debt for
something he's not sure he'll use
this is a kid who's actually really
really really level-headed and you and
your wife have done a fantastic job
and i applaud you for that so number one
dad
he's 19. i think you need to do what
most parents won't do and go hey kid
uh man i'm proud of you 20 grand you've
raised keep working
let's uh let's work on some ideas let's
let's explore some ideas let's
experiment a little bit with some things
that you may want to do
and don't put any pressure on him to go
to school you're already worried about
him going to a state school
and being a fish out of water or
something to those lines what you said
so
here's the thing what has the kid always
done very very well you tell me
well the to back up we've already had
that discussion with him
good told him several times how proud we
are of him
he's an amazing kid and i've told him i
said micah
if i had it to do over again i wish i
didn't go to college right out of high
school i says
no pressure my friend i said we love you
we'll support you
what does he like to do he loves doing
graphics
good and anything anything computer
related he's that kid that if you have a
problem with your computer
you go up to them and you say you know
this isn't working can you tell me why
i didn't give you half an hour on why
it's not working and how to fix it
what is he doing now what is that is
that related to the job he's doing now
no when he was 16 he started working
at a restaurant that it's a popular
burger and fry place
it opened over two years ago okay he was
one of their first employees
and now he's been a manager for
here's what i want you to do tonight i
want you to ask him if
if he knew that he could not fail but he
didn't have to commit for the rest of
his life
what profession would he try for fun
just a fun adventure and my guess is
going to say something to with graphic
design or something technology related
wouldn't you guess
yes yes you're correct then let's get
him in that
absolutely go online tonight get him to
say that
and then you go awesome let's do some
research together how can me and your
mom support you
to try several things in that area so
have him list out
graphic design maybe one um
i'm making this up right now video game
design two you know whatever he says
and then go online and look for training
programs
that are online and it could be at a
state school it could be in a
non-traditional
uh non-college type thing could be just
a
a private sector training thing i tell
you right now uh
you need to go to betheltech.net brad
right now
betheltech.net they sponsor and partner
they can call with
ken coleman show and they're training
people you ready for this in less than
nine months and less than fifteen
thousand dollars
they're getting people ready for the
technology industry and they have an 85
emplacement rating starting at 75 000
and up would you would you be surprised
to know that my lovely bride already
brought that up to him several months
ago
all right so at bet at bethel and we
asked him is yeah what about bethel
and he said well i don't want to get a
job that i can be replaced
by he seems to think that kind of work
eventually is going to be obsolete
well if he's 19 he doesn't yeah he
doesn't know what he's talking about
here's the point i'm just giving you
them as one option if he wants to do
graphic design and things of that nature
then then
get him a graphic design training
program see if he can get a job locally
uh he's 19. he's got a good paying job
what if he shadowed a couple of graphic
designers in your area
what if he worked for free uh for a
couple of
hours a week five to ten hours a week if
you will uh following something around
those are the things that he needs to do
right now brad
and once he gets a hold of it and he
tastes it and he sees it
and he gets experience with it um he's
going to
come up with it but you've got to
encourage him
and and push him towards the path he's
already looking down yeah don't over
complicate this yeah
don't do it don't do it at all and brad
also just
i want to say this he's 19. let him make
some mistakes
you know uh don't fight him on
everything that he says
don't fight him on everything that he
does you know hey give give him let's
explore yeah and just really really let
him
uh explore america do you ever feel like
you're always
you will always be stuck paying off your
debt
or that you'll never have extra money to
save and spend
how you want if that sounds like you
then it's time for a new way of thinking
you have to you have to believe you can
get rid of debt and take control of your
money because here's the thing
you can and it will not take nearly as
long as you think it will
with ramsey plus we'll kick you off with
90 days of guided help so you can put
more of your money back in your bank
account
not theirs but yours you'll learn
practical ways to get
small consistent wins that add up to big
huge results and better habits and that
means
you'll get you'll get where you want to
be
faster 100 debt free and spending your
money without worry
this year you can let me say this again
you can make more progress on your debt
and saving than you ever have get ramsey
plus and start
living the life you want faster
to reset your money and to start ramsey
plus for free
america for free do me a favor ashley no
do yourself a favor
go to daveramsey.com that is
daveramsey.com right now
and sign up for ramsey plus 100
free for 90 days listen uh ramsay plus
changed my life years ago ken
um because inside of ramsay plus is
financial peace university
and when i took that class i was
drowning in debt
i didn't really understand the power of
true stewardship
and i mean when i took that class not
only did i understand the biblical
meaning of stewardship
the correct meaning of stewardship but
now i knew how to move forward now
now i know how to move forward with my
finances and i'm telling everyone right
now
financial peace university inside of
ramsay plus with all the great stuff
ramsay plus
offers you are missing out if you're not
a part
of this community join the community and
i promise you it would change not just
your life
but your kids kids life but your
family's life this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight
eight two five five two two five we have
one full line
just opened up kelly is standing by and
she
will um i was about to say happily take
your phone call
she's always happy to answer your phone
calls but she chooses who actually
i'll get the makes makes it through so
give her a call
let her know uh the question and she
will let you know if you can come
through
if you make it through ken and i would
love to talk to you
just like how we're about to have a
conversation with paul in dallas texas
good afternoon paul how can ken and i
help
good afternoon guys thank you for taking
my call yeah um
so look i just started listening to the
show last month
we are currently on data step number two
my household income is 89 000. i'm the
only one that works
my wife stays home with our one-year-old
baby
and my question is the only debt that we
have is
my car which is around 32
000 32 000
yeah 32 000 what kind of car is this
this is a lincoln nationalist
okay so you driving nice nice what year
is it
yeah it's a 2019. okay yeah you're
driving real nice
nice nice yeah i wish that i would have
known that the baby was coming you know
i would have gotten something else
yeah i understand um anyways so
but but but that's the only depth that
we have we don't have any credit card
or anything else um but my question is
like like i was saying i just recently
started
uh listening to the show so i'm already
contributing
15 of my income
between my 401k at work and my roth ira
uh and my 41k is also rough so it's
i i have both on ross my question is
uh obviously i'm trying to pay off the
car as quickly as i can
at least that's my plan so my question
is should i pause
my 401k contributions to then use that
extra
money to send on top of what i already
sent
for my car and try to pay that off um
as quickly as i can well paul what you
just said
sounds so beautiful like you literally
just answered your own question that
sounds amazing
what you just said is should i pause
investing into my future so i can take
care of my present
so i can set my future up to be sitting
sitting on solid foundation yes so the
answer to your question is
absolutely um you have two scenarios
here
okay um and scenario number one is
some people are probably screaming he
needs to go sell the car
that's what probably a lot of people are
saying if you go sell the car and you go
buy you something cash and use
i don't have a problem with that but
with this being your only debt compared
to your income
i don't have a problem with you keeping
it as long as you get aggressive after
it
you know but if you i think you and your
wife need to sit down and say hey you
know what
uh this is a lot of car okay um i mean
if it's 30 something thousand dollars
right now this means you probably bought
it at 50 you bought it brand new
yeah it was brand new it was like i
guess 43 44
right now yep yep yeah 43 44 and after
taxes you paid about 50 grand
and so you've already have about 12 13
000 invested into this vehicle
so if i was in your shoes with this
being your only debt
i'm going to stop all my investments i'm
going to figure out how can i even
generate an extra 15 grand this year
to go towards that i'm trying to figure
out how to have this car paid off within
the next
six months before before the baby comes
that's what i'm really trying to do
and if you look at it and you see you
can't pay it off this year within the
next six months to a year
by the end of this year i'm selling the
car i'm gonna sell the car
and i'm going to buy me something cash
but if you can get aggressive paul i
would say keep it just pay it off
okay yeah because my only concern was
that you know
um i'm i'm i'm shooting to retire by 57
okay so my my only concern was like you
know
i'm probably gonna lose out a year or
maybe like 15 months you know while i
pay off the car
uh in the sense that i won't be going
contributing
that was my only concern because you
know i don't i don't really want to go
over it like
57 will be ideal and i know i can make
it but i don't really want to go over
60. all right paul
so paul let me let's just jump in here
how much is the car worth today if you
sell it
kelly blue value 26 000
okay so you're upside down at it a whole
lot yeah yes
yes yes a lot uh well
so again you get to determine i mean
first of all you're not going to lose
that much ground
no uh that's that's a myth that you're
going to lose that much ground
on your retirement investing you're
going to be able to make up
ground by the amount of money you're
going to put into it when you're
debt-free so i would
i would go at this car everything you
got you know and again
i'll just tell you this is me personally
i think ao is absolutely right
i don't disagree with what he's saying
i'm gonna tell you if it was
me feeling what you're feeling i'd sell
the car
dave's giving this advice before and i'd
go get the the six thousand dollar
you know difference in a loan and uh and
and and then whatever cash you got you
know you get something that's just
reliable a five thousand dollar car or
whatever yeah and then pay off that six
thousand and then you're right back into
the plan that's what i would do that
would speed everything up
yeah a whole lot do you have any savings
at all right now
uh what i have is uh
fourteen hundred dollars for you know
for for baby step one
okay um that's that's all that i have uh
i know i'm getting
at least like five thousand dollars on
my tax refund this year
okay uh that i'm planning to put towards
uh the car right okay uh so i know
that's coming in probably late this
month
okay because i already have my taxes
yeah
um so that will be extra money that i
have coming in but
other than that i have i have 1400 hours
in in savings yeah so and then
i don't know if it helps you guys i'm
also like i i have
around eighty four thousand dollars
right
between my 401k and my rough okay
and i'm 33 years old yeah so you're in
great shape yeah you're in great shape
they're fine
just knock this car out yeah however you
choose to do it knock the car
out you're not going to get behind
retirement yeah and paul here's the
thing man
you have to sit down and ask yourself do
i want to it should not take you a year
and a half to pay off this car
if you're going to decide to keep the
car you have to get aggressive after it
you have to say you know in the next six
months
i'm going to attack this thing or you
could take ken's suggestion
is go sell it take out a loan for the 6
000 for those of y'all hearing this
oh my goodness they're saying take out a
loan listen he's going from a 30 plus
thousand dollar loan down to a 6 000
loan he paid off a lot of debt right
there so we don't have a problem with
that
but the problem he's going to run into
is ken he doesn't have the cash
yeah so to go purchase the card well
that's where i take that tax refund i go
buy myself a four thousand dollar car
and then i put a thousand on the six and
now i only owe
five and i'm rocking and rolling yep so
there's just ways to do it
absolutely you know and and if making 90
000
a year i'm trying to figure out how do i
generate another 15 grand to have this
car paid off within six months
it's a nice car you know and so um
i would get aggressive on my end
especially at 33 years old man he could
be driving for uber he could be driving
we met a young lady last week not last
week but the week before that ken
um i don't know if he was nose john me
and john
met a young guy he made 78 000
in one year driving for uber yeah so
if you get aggressive if you are
determined it can happen yes and it
will happen yes but you have to be the
one to say you know what
i'm going to do this and so there's no
way inward on making 90 grand it's going
to take me a year and a half to pay off
and here's another way i mean we just he
could he could go bust it
work a couple jobs take that tax payment
and he could actually get that car
car what he owes on the car down to
where if he sells it he does make some
money
absolutely so i mean there's we've given
him three ways to to get
there um the reality is though paul um
ao is right it's the right question yes
you need to walk the baby steps out we
we pause retirement and we walk out the
baby steps you got the thousand dollars
in the emergency fund
and now we're gonna pay the car off then
we get to the three to six months
emergency fund then we start doing 15
percent
yes towards our retirement so walk it
out your 33 years young
yes you're in good shape you're going to
be fine you're going to make up so much
more ground
walking the plan absolutely man and
what's the point of investing into your
future you don't even have a
an emergency fund you might have a child
come no get out of debt get you three to
six months set aside and then boom start
investing into
not just your future but even now your
new child's future
come on now let's think america let's
think oh man
man this is a great hour ken always
always fun to be with you always
want to thank kelly james and everybody
in the
studio over there this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit daveramsey.com
show and register we would love for you
to come to nashville and tell your story
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have
a conversation about your life and your
money and especially today
your career moves my name is anthony
o'neill host of the popular youtube and
podcast show the table with
anthony o'neil and co-hosting with me is
number one national best-selling
author and uh also host of the number
one career
show uh in my opinion in the world
thank you the ken coleman show is very
creative we spent many many hours
yes and lots of dollars coming up with
that creative name
i know that was very creative i was
wondering where did you get the ken
coleman
and hey listen so we're going to do a
little ken coleman show along with the
table
yeah anthony o'neil plus some ramsay
show
all together we're talking about your
life your money and we'll take your
calls about
hey i'm not where i want to be i need a
bigger shovel ken
help me figure out how i can do
something i'm good at something i love
create results i want and make
the money hey man so when you make the
money with ken
come over and holler at me he's gonna
show you how to use the money that's it
you know so this is a tag team it works
well you know
you know what kelly james we need to do
this more often
okay career get the money me i'll show
you how to spend the money
how to use it wisely let's go ahead and
make this happen as a matter of fact
uh i'll talk to dave i'll tell him he
can take some time off and
we'll take care of it yeah copy me on
that
[Laughter]
kelly wants to be copied on that as well
because things really go well when
people tell dave
oh yeah i'm gonna tell them i don't know
you know what that's i'm gonna tell dave
you know
that's what i'm gonna say go golf in two
more days on me as a matter of fact
he probably will he probably you're
paying then man knows how to save a buck
he knows how to save a buck oh man hey
this is the ramsay show give us a call
kelly is standing by the phone lines
right now
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i see one line is open
um but right now we're gonna go out to
minneapolis and talk to andrew
andrew good afternoon how can ken and i
help
ken and anthony thank you so much uh for
taking my call today
my wife and i are currently in fpu and
it's been such a blessing for us
we walked into this with a 143 000 of
non-mortgage debt
and in the past uh five weeks of doing
this class we've been able to pay off
but roughly fifteen thousand dollars
wow way to go andrew that's awesome come
on somebody
come on yes sir i feel that i feel the
lord
yeah right right and it's all because
we've done a lot of the steps right
we've been able to renegotiate things
from internet to we've cut out cable and
stopped uh acting normal right and got
the budget going and then
you know looked at universal life
policies like this was crazy what are we
thinking right so getting into turn so
uh we're able to flow about uh an extra
you know doing all those steps about
extra 800 bucks a month just to our
bottom line you know we have a little
money to play with
but uh you know we're like i said we're
in uh you know step five i mean i'm
sorry
baby step two and wanting to pay off
that uh 143 000
and and deep in myself i just want to
continue to be gazelle
and i have a great job and you know our
net income is roughly about 107 000
a year and i want to pick up a side gig
and i
i have a passion for real estate and i
always enjoy it i love learning about it
and watching my friends buy homes and
stuff like that and i have this desire
possibly to
get my real estate license but i know
it's going to be roughly a thousand
dollars up front right
but i'm sitting on a hundred and you
know roughly now let's call 118 thousand
dollars
i'm sorry 123 000 in debt is it wise for
me
in in this current state and being step
two to invest that thousand dollars to
get my real estate license
to help continue to be gazelle uh and do
that on the side
while i do my normal gig i'll be quiet
and listen to you guys
how much research have you done into
what it takes to win
as a real estate agent um
with the amount of time that you're
going to have because you got a
full-time job so have you done any
research talking with some successful
people and what it takes to get started
how many hours they recommend i'm just
curious what your thoughts are on that
yeah and you know uh to be completely
transparent there hasn't been a lot of
deep dive recently
uh it was something that was on my mind
three four five years ago so i sat down
with a couple uh real estate agents and
and brokers in the area
uh and you know almost every single
person was like you can't do this
part-time you can't do this part-time
is true but then i i do see some people
that say hey you can do this part-time
uh and i would say right now i'm not in
the place where i would want to leave my
job i feel like i have the dream job i
love what i do
and it pays well uh so all right so
here's my take
i think that's what i'm stuck no it's
good it's absolutely great i wanted to
know what you thought because i've
talked to some some great
real estate uh professionals people that
are that train other real estate
professionals
and and and and you cannot do real
estate part-time
as a full-time income but if you're
doing it part-time as a part-time job
i absolutely think you should do it
because i think you can do it well
for part time so let me repeat what i
said those people have told you that
they're absolutely right
you can't do real estate part-time if
you want it to pay
full time but if you want to just sell a
house
here and there and let's say you make a
nice 12 000 commission or 18 or 12 or 30
or whatever it is
okay uh depending how big the house is
in your market
you can use it to pay off debt and in
that case uh if you're doing nights and
weekends and you're busting at your
gazelle intense you're trying to show
homes
at nights and weekends uh as a part-time
side hustle to help pay off debt
absolutely i think you should spend the
thousand dollars to get qualified
i really do uh i i agree i agree i would
say do a little bit more research and
again i'm not i'm not an expert
in this area ken is the expert in career
field uh
but i do think there's a little bit more
of front investment
in the real estate agents like you got
to pay for signage you got to pay for
marketing of the house and stuff like
that
i mean i could be wrong but i think
there there are a little bit more so
what i would suggest is if you go this
route
i want you to be very careful on how
much money
you're pulling away from paying off debt
to
possibly sell some houses so i like the
idea
yeah but i do think that there are like
you got to pay for signage you got to
pay for
do you have a broker relationship
already that you're working somebody
would take you under their wing for
those kind of expenses that ao is
talking about
you know i i do not uh like i said i
have some really good friends that have
been doing this
uh for many years uh actually i got a
couple friends have been doing it for 20
30 years right that's where you start
that's where you start today as a matter
of fact before uh before this week is
over you need to have had several
conversations whether in person on the
phone
to actually go through what anthony's
talking about i took you at face value
on the thousand dollars for just the
getting trained in the testing but
uh if you get i would love for you to
get underneath somebody who's a really
successful broker in the area
that would cover a lot of that stuff she
wouldn't have to worry a lot about that
and they take you under their wing
ideally some of those people have been
in there a long time if you sit down and
go hey guys
i've always wanted to do this um
can you guide me yeah would you bring me
along that's good
and explain why you're doing it say hey
i'm trying to knock out 143 000
in debt uh i think that's a wonderful
wonderful strategy
yep i totally agree i totally agree
andrew hey i'm rooting for you man
you are winning yeah i mean fifteen
thousand dollars paid off in the last
two weeks and
you could tell he's really excited you
know he's really really really really
excited about paying off his debt
and i love how you you're starting to
think okay what can i do to generate
some more income
just be wise find you a broker see if
they'll take on the fees for you
and if they do go hard man go hard
you'll be out of debt this year six
percent
on a three hundred thousand dollar house
now he's gonna pay taxes on that but
that's still a big chunk towards dutch
that's beautiful that's been i like that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits secure your future today
visit nationalguard.com ramsey
to find out more
[Music]
edward is with us in birmingham good
afternoon edward
how can ken and i help
hello hey edward
anthony yes sir how can we help man
hi a huge privilege speaking with you
thank you for taking the call
yeah uh this one because
i got some several dilemmas recently uh
got out of the military about a little
less than a year ago
i've been in fellowships walking with
the lord and
i've been following along with the randy
show for quite a while
the family is uh rather difficult to get
along with
doing a lot of exactly what's taught in
the day register is
specifically what not to do already
enrolled in financial peace university
and some of the dilemmas here is being
at square one now or
already seeing a therapist uh
to have a meaningful conversation and to
use the right words here but
uh long story short just wrestling with
a quality place to begin
can you be more specific i i was
tracking with you a little bit
where to begin what yeah
word began at least with like employment
getting back up uh getting back up on
the seat
yeah okay gotcha that was a lot of time
uh delve a lot of toxic leadership and
that time not to miss just to
unpack anything here but long story
short uh
been struggling trying to actually put
any of these teachings like into
any kind of practicality here okay so uh
first of all
thank you for serving us on our country
you're a great american
um what what have you sought to do when
you get out of the military what field
do you want to be in what kind of work
do you want to be doing
well been praying regularly for that
fortunately dealing with uh now having a
freedom and latitude here
there's a variety of options available
whether it be
as a temporary solution here
lows or construction
but unfortunately wrestling with some uh
difficulty or uh figuring out what that
next move is meant to be
okay so here's the deal here's that's
okay i feel
like we're not quite sure what when you
say you don't have freedom or latitude
what do you mean
well i mean getting out the marine corps
it wasn't a choice that i actually had
for uh to make the contract was over but
now i do have a lot more freedom here
okay so you're out of the military and
and from my understanding you correctly
you can decide wherever you want to go
in birmingham alabama and
and go apply for a job nothing's holding
you back from going after work correct
essentially well yeah essentially so yes
all right and and and so what would you
try tomorrow what what
why are you just limiting yourself to a
home improvement store what do you want
to do what would you do edward
if you knew you couldn't fail if you
didn't have to spend any money to get
qualified i just put you in it right now
what would you do what would you try
uh maybe in the justice department
great and be more specific what would
you do in the justice department what's
that look like
uh yeah
go ahead and say dating you just don't
wanna there's only really come to mind
right now
okay and you've always been somebody who
really is kind of intrigued and you kind
of get down to the details you ask lots
of questions
that's something that's kind of a
pattern in your life is that that talent
of of investigation
well there is a very regular pattern of
asking questions and trying to
understand to
understand something yeah unfortunately
there's uh people skills can be a little
bit rusty
that's okay here's the deal so you want
to figure out how to so right now are
you employed at all
no okay you need to get employed though
one of the worst things that can happen
to anybody is to be out of work for a
while it causes tremendous trauma
you begin to start to doubt your
self-worth and then that's a really
really slippery slope how long have you
been out of the marines
uh almost a year okay and you've not
been working
looking for it no i didn't say that i
said have you been working
at all since you've been out of the
military
no you need to so let's get out let's
get out tomorrow
did you were you honorably i mean there
was no dishonorable discharge none of
that correct
no it's just uh general discharge okay
so
so edward listen you got to get your
mojo man yeah and so until you can
figure out what type of work you'd like
to do in the just department whether
that be on the local
level the state level or the federal
level you need to start looking into
that
today what does it take to get qualified
what are the types of jobs do i want to
be a law enforcement officer
do i want to work for the fbi and be
more on the criminal and forensic side
you've got to start really looking into
that stuff and and when you do so your
heart is going to
uh really uh make it very clear to you
that oh that seems
exciting to me and we look into that we
say what does it take to get there
meaning how do i get qualified then we
ask well how
how much is that going to cost how long
is that going to take
based on my financial realities my
friend you need to be working right now
so if you want to go work at a home
improvement store i'm all for that i'm
all for a second job
you're a young man you've got to get
anthony he's got to get feeling good
about himself again to say i'm working
i'm bringing in money i now have a plan
to look and investigate some ideas for
my future
once i look at those then i come up with
the other plan again i gave you the four
questions
here are the four qualifying questions
ao that'll help people not be so
so freaked out by the unknown number one
once we have an idea of what we'd like
to do
we look into say what does it take to
get qualified four questions
the experience excuse me the education
question is first what do i need to
learn
does it have to be a traditional college
degree could be a training course
certification whatever
second question is the experience
question what do i need to do
third question is the economic question
how much is that going to cost me and
then finally based on my financial
reality yes
the budget how long will this take me to
cash flow my way through it debt free
degree is an
example of that anthony's book so once
we get the answers to those four
questions ao we've got ourselves
the ingredients of a recipe if you want
to use that analogy so oh we know how to
cook this
i know how to do this and this young man
needs to get hired he needs to start
working stocking some money away so that
he can pay and cash flow his way
through this process all right okay you
hit that one on the head man
i read a study recently you're a former
pastor i read a study recently that said
that when someone is out of work is
up to six months ao listen to this
that the trauma is the same the
emotional trauma
is the same as losing a loved one oh man
and you understand this as well as
anybody speak to that that speaks to
somebody's i
they're like hey i'm not doing anything
i don't feel like i'm making a
difference i don't feel like i matter we
know that's not true
not true but that's how they feel but i
mean i think when you
and again i don't know the study so i
could be off i'm just going by
a general thought i think that study is
probably even higher with men
yes you're right because men we identify
ourselves by what we do
by providing for our families or
providing for ourselves
so we're not able to provide we feel
that we've lost a huge part of who we
are as a man and let's be real yeah we
have
and so uh i agree that this young man
needs to get out there
just so he can have peace with okay i am
a working
man then from there he needs to be
connected with you your brand to really
start identifying okay what's my sweet
spot
where do i go from there yeah let's make
sure kelly that
edward goes to my website kencoleman.com
get the career clarity guide a very
simple free worksheet
worksheet under my resources page that
will walk him through the exercise to
begin to get more ideas and really
verify
this idea of law enforcement of the
justice system
um and to begin to see what's what's out
there one of the things you and i preach
to young people is
if you've got a general direction of
which way you might want to go
go look at multiple if you say well i'm
interested maybe in medicine and
healthcare well go
shadow go meet a nurse practitioner yes
uh or a physician's assistant
or a surgeon uh or whatever and begin to
explore what it's like to do this work
day in
and day out absolutely man can you hit
it all good man
that's why i like doing the show with
you because you know how to answer the
question and teach man
being a professor i'm trying to hang
with you man you're the professional
preacher
i'm trying to hang with you i'm just a
preacher's kid so i just got a little
bit by osmosis you know what i mean just
being in the house
you know y'all man we have one phone
line just open up triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five
five two two five uh kell is standing by
we would love to take your phone calls
right here on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my name is anthony o'neill hosting with
me today co-hosting together
uh ken coleman the radio host of the
kenny coleman show and
my name anthony o'neil host of the
popular youtube show
uh the table with anthony o'neill before
we go any further you know i really want
you all to make sure
uh that you all are listening uh every
single day to the king coleman show
um it's available every every weekday on
siriusxm
uh your local radio stations wherever
you listen to podcasts
i would definitely say get up in the
mornings if you're looking at how do i
land my dream job how do i
even improve uh build relationships with
inside of my dream job how do i go from
where i'm at now to a higher
level within side of my dream job i
really want you to
connect with my dear friend um and my
colleague ken coleman who's the host of
the ken coleman show
where he focused on works that matters
follow him on facebook at ken coleman's
show
also instagram and twitter the ken
coleman not the king coleman show
on instagram and twitter but the ken
coleman and they get the book the
proximity principle the proven strategy
that will lead to the career you love
and i'll tell you right now america he's
working on something special he got two
big things he's working on
i won't say it because i don't want to
get in no trouble that's not my brand
oh but america when i tell you you want
to be following his show
you want to be following him on
instagram
because he is working on things uh that
that's going to impact all of us
including myself and so i i want to
encourage you all to please listen to
him
uh listen to the show call into the show
ask him some questions
read his book follow him on instagram
thank you my man
hey man i appreciate that but listen now
i get to i mean the table is now in
podcast form
it is people know you on youtube the
table's been rocking
on youtube in fact last year an
explosive year would
be a mild way of putting it but now
you're bringing the table
audio to podcast wherever you listen to
your favorite podcast go check it out
because you're taking on some big
conversations
and uh this is really good stuff i
highly recommend it because anthony's
got his finger on the pulse
uh so every episode excuse me every
monday he's got a new episode the table
now
in podcast form not just on youtube so
doing some good stuff over there thank
you ken that's what we do
tag team yeah man lift each other hey i
was on fox news last week
you are and they have they asked me a
question and student loan debt came up
so here i am and i just did a little
whoop just turned
just just moved over a little bit said
hey let me tell you about my colleague
let me give me get that out let me tell
you about my colleague anthony o'neil i
did i i did i threw my own
i threw my own pass and dunked it for my
man
yeah the number one best-selling book
debt-free degree and i think it's still
as relevant as the day he wrote it
because we got a lot of kids they're
going to come out of school
ao in may and they're gonna be saddled
with
crazy debt they are they are it's right
over there look at that it's right over
there to our left
as i say it it's in my my peripheral on
the bookcase
listen looking good all right ken i'll
uh
i'll give you a good tip when we get off
i love it let's help some people let's
help some people hey triple eight eight
two five
five two two five we have one phone line
open man y'all y'all are calling in like
crazy today kelly's standing by
uh she can squeeze one person in uh for
this segment but hey give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go out to toledo ohio and
have a conversation with charles
charles good afternoon how can ken and i
help
hey thanks for taking my phone call so
um
got married in in 17 uh 2017.
we had we do have joint accounts all of
our accounts are
our joint accounts both on both um
we got married well
the question is i'm wondering if i
should let her
finish paying off her car or if i should
just
do it myself because i'm getting tired
of having it now to explain that you
know after saying we have joined
accounts
yeah when we got married the agreement
was she was going to stay home
and do some couponing about time we got
married
i started couponing and i really fell in
love with couponing i i
loved it i felt like i was stealing from
the stores you know they were
paying me to carry their stuff out of
the stores
so i told her you know i said i make
pretty decent money 28
an hour i said you know i can work all
the hours i want i work
pretty much 60 hours right now sometimes
one more a week
i said i'll make the money you stay home
and save us money
take care of the kids take care of the
house you know go to the gym et cetera
none of that really happened very well
and i finally assumed okay maybe she
just can't coupon well she has a hard
time looking at two products and only
which one's the better deal
um you know so
she ended up getting a part-time job 13
an hour which is about all she's ever
done
as retail stuff and so i'm trying to
encourage her
to because i know when i paid off my car
when i had a loan before for my car i
paid it off and that felt great
so i told her i said okay when you get
your paycheck every other friday
you know take out what you want for you
you're spending money and then put the
rest on the car
yeah and she's been plinking away at it
about
uh four or five maybe six hundred
dollars every two weeks
it's like trying to shoot a bear with
the title okay hold on all right
all right all right all right charles
charles okay i tried
i appreciate what you're saying yeah
something's not lining up so if you two
are on joint accounts
that means you guys are making your
money decisions together
then you shouldn't be calling us asking
us if you should pay off your wife's car
and then you tell us a story that she's
not paying enough out of her
13 hour job if you've got the money to
pay it off pay it off why do you need
my permission or ao's permission and you
certainly don't need her permission
other than buy-in to say this is our
money
but you're you're saying you have joint
accounts but you're acting as though you
have two separate
uh accounts and and she's just kind of
paying it off
whenever she wants to if you want the
car to be paid off sit down with her and
cast
vision and say we're going to pay it off
i i don't know what's missing here
the only thing i left out and i
apologize for leaving this out is
i wanted her to feel good about paying
it off so maybe
she could do what i did which is like
wow i paid that off
i need to go make more money no it's not
working charlie prove
my life charles she's not wired the way
you're wired you're mr coupon guy
not her yeah yeah and here's the problem
that i keep hearing
charles and and i'm not married
so you know i told the producer james
the other day i'm gonna be careful
how i say things because i'm not married
all right set me up and then i'll hit it
i'm gonna set you up all right um
they can't be divided i ca i keep
hearing her car
her money her this and it's not a we
it's not a
are we gonna do this is not our account
it's her money this
that i feel separation within a marriage
yeah is this the only debt you have
it is it's the only other than the house
mortgage and i was just hoping it might
be encouraging
no stop charles charles charles we've
already gone down this path
i'm gonna keep cutting you off if you
keep trying to go down this you're it's
you're treating her like she's your
teenage
daughter i can't wait to get married
dude how much is the car
how much is how much is owed on the car
700 bucks that's been killing me for the
last one oh my gosh i'm hanging up the
phone it's the first time i'm gonna hang
up on somebody yeah hang it up i can't
do it yeah i can't do it no more
this is ridiculous charles this is
ridiculous pay the car off today oh my
gosh
i've never ever hung up on anybody
what's going on
this just happened he said i thought he
was going to say like
8 000 i'm trying to get my wife to pay
off the car
with her 13 an hour job 700
i want her to feel good pay the car off
oh i didn't say nothing but listen
there's
i'm not even see i'm sorry james i'm not
even asking my wife i'm just cutting the
check
i'm just gonna cut the check baby i paid
off your card um you know what i do
i would i'd spend 750 tonight
700 to pay the car off 50 on flowers and
tell her what you did
come on what is happening here she's
clearly not interested in paying it off
we got a communication problem on top of
all this oh
my goodness i mean what a good guy but
now charles listen you're a good man
your heart's in the right place i think
your brain is totally
in a different place you all need to get
back on the same page
and say i'm making this decision for us
this isn't about having your wife feel
good about herself
get rid of the 700 get out of debt this
guy
he wants to yeah he knows how and you
know what as a matter of fact i would
suggest that you too
you two together go listen to one of our
uh teammates here
john delonay you all need some
counseling together you all need to talk
through this
together because uh there's no way in
the world i'm having this kind of
conversation
with my wife i'm just being honest i'm
sorry if i offend anyone but
i'm not babe i paid off the cop god
bless you i love you
here's some roses this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague anthony
o'neil and
ao i'm excited about this because
uh we need more great people yes sir
to do great work uh ramsey solutions
we're all about transforming lives we
want to disrupt the toxic culture
in the area of money obviously work
relationships mental emotional health
and beyond
and to be able to do that level of
disruption we need great people
who are sold out to the same mission and
uh we now have a thousand people at our
company
it's hard to believe until we sit
together in staff meeting like we did
this morning we see all those great
great faces so we need more people and
if you want to join us on that crusade
we're currently on the hunt
for software engineers with expertise in
ruby on rails java c-sharp
and front-end technologies or if you're
a ux designer seo and content marketing
specialist
we'd also like to talk with you find out
about all the available jobs we have
many many more than just those
technology jobs
and you can find out more by texting the
phrase
work that matters that's one phrase
no spaces work that matters text work
that matters to 33789 that's three
three seven eight nine and uh maybe
we'll see in the building soon
hey i met a sharp lady uh today right
after staff meeting
uh she had listened to the ken coleman
show called my show about six months ago
she didn't tell me she was applying to
this company but she was asking me
advice for how to to get in a certain
place
and towards the end i kind of figured it
out and i said you wouldn't be
applying for ramsey solutions would you
and she said yes i said well if you get
in
and it's hard to get in here yeah it is
but i said if you get in
come see me someday after staff meeting
today she came up and said hi
started a month ago i love it so we need
some great people work that matters text
that phrase to three three seven eight
nine i love it i love it since you're
leading us man where we going next
oh let's see go to kyle in birmingham
cows in birmingham hey kyle good
afternoon how can uh
uh how about say chris hogan can i help
you out
yeah i've got a inheritance question
yeah
my my siblings and i received an
inheritance from my
father's mother and he passed away years
ago
um it's only 55 000 divided six ways
so we each get a little less than nine
thousand dollars a piece
and we're trying to figure out the best
way to use that money to care for my
mother
in the future she has historically not
been great with money okay
and i've been trying to help her but i
still i don't
love the idea of just giving her the
money so i'm trying to figure out how
what the best vehicle would be to keep
the money save it for her
and help care for her when she's older
cool how old is your mom right now
she is 62. okay how much debt is she in
right now
um she is debt-free um
and has last i talked to her about 120
000
total and savings okay okay let me ask
you this question
why do you feel that you cannot trust
your mom with the money
yeah so when my father passed away um i
became heavily involved in helping her
with the transition um
and i got her debt free we dealt with
all of the finances and i had her
uh set up so that if she took
if she lived off of the interest alone
she would have
money for you know the rest of her life
um and she burned through the stockpile
so she burned through all the reserves
and all that she was left with
was the house and then she sold the
house cool and that's kind of what she
has left
i got you i got you ken what are you
thinking i have a question about all the
siblings
is everybody in agreement that they are
going to each give their 9 000
the sum total being 55 to help your mom
in retirement
no it's a mix a couple of us that have
had a pretty
decent year are willing to give all of
it some of us who have been unemployed
for the last year
need to keep some of this everybody's
wanting to give some
and a couple of us more than others well
i think then we find out what the number
is and then i think you need to sit down
with one of our smartvestor pros
i mean that's why we have these men and
women fanned out all around the country
and i would sit down with a couple do
you actually work with one of our smart
investor pros now
on your own retirement i do i'd sit down
well then that's where i would go i'd
start there because you've got to trust
a relationship so
i'd go to your smartvestor pro and i'd
say all right here's the deal
um we've got let's just say the number
is 25 for round numbers so that's what
the total is whatever here's what we've
got here's what here's what my history
is with mom here's what she's done
how can we how can we put this some
money away where she doesn't touch it
but i mean
my guess is and i'm going to give you a
general answer i'm not dave ramsey
but my answer is is that she's not she's
not touching her current retirement you
say it was about 120 000 she's not
trying to do anything squirrely with
that right
no she's not then i would put it into
that so to me it's just piling on what
she already
has that's where you're gonna get the
best return but again your smart vester
pro is
is the person to talk to you about the
specifics of what she currently has
and how to make the most of that money
yeah but i since she's proven she's not
she's not being she's not being just
crazy by trying to take out her
retirement
so i'd just pile it on to what she has
that's the best use of that money sounds
like to me
and i would definitely as well kyle have
a conversation with your mother just
pull it to the side so here mom
we need to start making strategic moves
to set you up for retirement to set you
up to
win successfully financially in these
next few years
um and so we're going to make some wise
decision with
this pot of money that we're going to
give back to you
but then also let's sit down with a
smart investor pro like ken
said and let's figure out okay how do we
invest
more and then two months you have to
make better financial decisions as well
okay you can't just be out here doing
this and doing that
we need you to make strategic moves that
sets you up
to win in the future because mom if we
can set you up in a healthy place
this helps out your kids and we're not
stressed we're not
hurting our families but um we can still
help you out so i would definitely
uh to have a conversation with your mom
first then reach out to a smart investor
pro
then make some moves from there but such
a great question
uh there kyle thank you so much for
calling and praying for you praying for
your mom and praying for the whole
family
um that uh this will be an easy process
uh real quickly we're gonna go out to
phoenix arizona have a conversation with
john good afternoon john how can ken and
i help
hi i'm going to ask about selling my
three rental properties in order to pay
off my home mortgage
recently we decided to have my wife
leave her job to stay home with the kids
and our income has decreased by half
to 72 000 okay um
if i restructure this way i can better
meet savings goals and have more
breathing room in the budget which is
pretty tight right now
okay how much do you own your home
uh about three hundred thousand dollars
um
part of the reason we're getting this
squeeze is uh it puts me above
the 25 uh threshold for
monthly home payment how much would you
clear if you sell the three rentals
uh 307 000 approximately
so right at the right at the number yeah
i have i also have a good cash savings
as well right now but i probably need to
sell at least two of the rental
how much do you have in savings uh 178
thousand dollars in like
uh liquid savings is what i would call
it what's your household income
72 000 okay i thought you said you went
down by 72 okay
and this is the only debt you you have
is your actual home
uh my home and the investment properties
right right right right
cool well yeah i i
i'm well to be honest with you i don't
know that i would sell all three
do you what do you do are you how much
do you uh what what's the one that you
owe the least amount on the rentals or
the three
the one that i own the least on yeah how
much is that worth
um well they're all slight they're all
pretty different in equity
two of the houses uh one has a hundred
thousand dollars of equity
one has a hundred and forty thousand
dollars of equity and one has sixty
seven thousand so
if we were going to keep one it'd
probably be the lowest equity because
it'd be
uh you know the least uh from getting
sellers you know
right well with 178 in the bank i mean
the way we teach
we teach the baby steps and i'm sure
you're familiar with them if you're not
three to six months expenses is what we
have you put in a
uh emergency fund so what's what's your
six month on
72 your take home is what
about five uh per month
yeah i think it's more like 42 42. okay
here's the deal i would use some of that
cash yeah only sell one or two of the
homes keep
one yeah uh pay off the main house and
then and then attack those rental
properties all right
right on right on i would do that or you
could sell all three and just you know
buy or sell all three yeah you gotta pay
cash yeah yeah
so not a bad idea right there ken you're
in great shape with that savings account
absolutely
absolutely we're proud of you this is
the ramsey shop
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money
my name is anthony o'neill host of the
popular youtubing podcast show the table
with anthony o'neil
and co-hosting with me today is ken
coleman
host of the king coleman show and number
one national best-selling author of the
proximity principle
and together today we're going to be
answering your questions around your
life
your money and your careers if you're
trying to figure out how do i
make my shovel bigger give us a call we
have the career expert
in the building who will show you how to
land that
job get that pay increase and then once
we can help you out over there then
uh he's gonna throw a alley hoop over
here to me and i'm gonna show you how to
use the money uh to pay off your debt
build wealth start investing
purchase your car you know i would i
want to see more young people can
get their dream jobs pay off their debt
when they pay off their debt they have a
fully funded emergency fund
and they're calling here saying hey how
do i build my dream home yes
how do i buy my dream car yes how do i
send my kids off to
to their school you know that's those
are the conversations that i'm looking
forward to having
down the road as we help people get out
of debt and we start seeing their kids
come up yes
with no debt and now they're saying hey
i was set up right
i just landed my dream job ken thank you
hey anthony how do i do this over here
so
um i really want to encourage you to
give us a call we have two phone lines
open here at the top of the hour triple
eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five
uh kelly is standing by uh and i'm i'm
excited i really am excited you excited
i am you know i love what you just said
you know one i i think that
one of the other things we'd see happen
as a result of that vision you gave us
is you know this well the mosaics gen z
the millennials
gen y they are a very socially aware
generation and i think we'd see people
doing more with that money as well
that would be so missional you know
people doing things to help others
starting non-profits or starting causes
you know or
uh just i i that this generation really
is
uh well these two generations that i
mentioned really are socially aware and
i think that
you know when when dave says and has
said for many many years live like no
one else so that later you can live
and give like no one else that give like
no one else i think
those two generations absolutely uh
could do some amazing things with that
money so i love that vision
and and i think i'd add that one little
thing right there because i think it
could be extraordinary
absolutely absolutely i agree with you
man well hey schuyler is with us in iowa
good afternoon uh skyler how can we help
thanks for having me um i guess
i kind of got late listening to dave
ramsey show and i did stuff
backwards from i guess the baby steps
and we have a lot of
money me and my fiance and savings
account but with her only working part
time
going to school being a nurse
practitioner gets very
anxiety about paying off some of the
debt with that just because she doesn't
work as much
i guess i just don't know the way to
help get her over that to get a couple
of our debts paid off
so when you say your fiance right now
when you say
help her get up help her get overweight
a little bit more specific
she just gets anxiety about spending
that money just because she's only
working part-time
and she she just uh i guess doesn't
she likes having that safety net there
even though it's a lot of money just
being set there how much is a lot of
money we got about
75 000 in savings and then another
13 000 in our wedding fund for may how
much money do you owe in debt
uh i was 16 on a truck and we have 8 000
on our student loans this is all we owe
so you owe 24 and you got 75 or 78 is
that what you said 78
yeah yeah and it's about 10 000 a
semester for a school
that we've been trying to pay up front
and she's you guys are cash flowing that
together right
yes i think you just have to sit down
with her and walk her through it and go
look
if we pay my truck off and we pay your
loan off okay that's
24 000 if i if i got the numbers right
is that correct
yep all right so show her what's left
it's the old math problem okay and you
show her what's left after that and you
go we still have
our 13 000 in our wedding fund we still
have
uh 78 and 24 what is that 58 and uh so
54 right
yeah and we both have good retirement
funds too yeah but yeah i'm not even
talking retirement because we're not
going to touch that
i'm saying you still have over 50 000 in
savings
plus the 13 and you guys are debt free
you got yours three to six months
already fully funded before you ever
walk down the aisle
there's nothing for her to have anxiety
over help her see how much money you
guys are gonna save per month
off of those debt payments show her that
number
yeah yeah let me ask you this uh when is
when are y'all getting married
uh may 1st okay so it's right around the
corner okay so march april may okay
okay cool typically what we teach um on
the money side of things is we don't
combine income
other than savings account for the
wedding until we are actually married
that's true that is correct so i would
definitely say
i would wait to combine your income to
pay off
debt you can take your money and pay off
your debt she could take her money and
pay off her debt
um how is that savings broken down thank
you for saying i was i was under the
impression it was your
your money that's a very good point
thank you for clarifying that how much
of that 78 is yours versus hers
she's got about uh 44 and i got about
34.
okay yeah so everything i said except
that i missed that thank you ao for
bailing me out there we don't want to
confuse folks
but she could still pay off hers yeah
she's still good she's only got eight
yeah yeah she's still gonna be in great
shape
yeah yeah so i agree she could pay off
hers you can save some of yours
uh to pay for the wedding or you all can
do that together but the key thing here
is that's what's in our savings uh
the wedding stuff is all suffering okay
perfect then yeah i
i agree with ken she can pay off hers
you can start attacking yours and go
from there but i
would not combine bank accounts until
the day after your marriage um and but i
mean
what you all are doing right now is is
it's great you have the money
uh to take care of that i will go ahead
and take care of it
um and i definitely won't let me let me
ask him real quick skyler yeah
what does she say when what what is her
anxiety that's just a fancy word
you know in this situation for fear what
is she afraid of if you
if she spends that eight grand of her 44
taking her down to 36 what is she scared
of specifically has she told you
not really that would that start always
just worries about it
well but so here's the deal so you
started off the call saying how can i
help her
i think you got to have a conversation
with and say hey what are you scared
about
if you cut a check today for 8 000 you
are debt free
and i'm gonna cut a check on my side you
get to decide so by the way ao is right
you need to lead you need to go ahead
and pay that truck off yeah
and show her show her how much you still
have left over and say what are you
scared of
because look at how much money i saved a
month to show her that car payment
and just show her how that plays out on
a depreciating
asset by the way so just show her some
real numbers but then say hey what are
you scared of let her tell you
once she tells you why you listen to her
and i know you're not gonna belittle it
but don't try to tear it apart just let
her voice what she's scared of and then
go hey
but you don't have to be scared of that
here's why and let her see how
big picture hey do you want to be on the
same page we've got to be on the same
page before we get married we got to get
we got to get on the same page
on the money stuff yeah and that's when
i tried to show her like
we looked up jobs and what she's going
to be making what she's done i'm like
you know if you're debt-free coming out
of it you know that's even going to be
there
in a year yeah this is a math this is a
math problem show her how the math
actually adds up
and you guys are gonna be in great shape
wow what a great way to start your
marriage
i love it i love it this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
same christian healthcare ministries or
chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget-friendly option
and the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
connor is with us in youngstown ohio
good afternoon connor how can ken
and i help hi um
so i'm 19 years old and newly married
[Music]
i was never really afforded the
opportunity to go to college based on my
circumstances
um and i just i needed to support myself
and be able to pay rent
after high school um
so well while i was in high school i got
a trade school degree
and currently i'm working as a machinist
um
okay so i just just recently got married
and i got myself in a little bit of a
mess during covid
um but i'm working on i'm on baby step
number two i have two credit cards paid
off and just
uh i married some student loan debt
but so i i have to pay that down and
then
i have a personal loan that i have to
take care of
but other than that everything's going
well getting the debt paid down pretty
quickly
ultimately i was just wondering since i
have to work full time
and i have another mouth to feed now um
i i was just debating on whether or not
college would be worth it
because i mean i i wasn't able to go out
of high school but
um and i know
you guys teach the student loan debt
isn't a good idea obviously
so um what do you want to do you're 19
so you're really young but
you've already been in the trades long
enough to get a good sense of what
that's like
what do you want well i worked i mean i
worked in a machine
shop through high school too part time
so i mean this is
about my fourth year doing it um i'm
making
almost 45 000 a year good i usually go
over with overtime
good right so i mean we make ends meet
just fine
uh cost of living in what do you mean
what do you want to do you're 19. what
do you allow yourself to dream about
when you're stuck at the stoplight
or you're mowing the grass or you're
working on what do you want to do when
you're 39 49 what do you want to do
successful
picture yourself what are you doing i
want to own my own shop someday
so you're doing the work you're doing
the work
you're getting paid connor you're
getting paid by somebody else
to learn how to run a shop so while
you're
doing one roll you your head needs to be
on a swivel and i'm guessing it already
is you sound like a really mature 19
year old
but you're you're just paying attention
to everything you can pay attention to
and then
if you're in a good relationship with
your leader right now eventually you're
taking him or her to lunch whoever's
running the shop over there and you're
saying hey
uh how do you do the books how do you
pay how do you save money on parts
you're learning everything you can
because one of these days you're going
to do it for yourself
so do you need to go to college i'm
going to flip the question on you
do you need to go to college to
eventually
become an entrepreneur
owner of your own shop business do you
well i mean i suppose i wouldn't i mean
i i would like
i've definitely thought about getting my
mechanical engineering degree because i
love
mechanical systems and design and just
figuring out how things
work how would that help you achieve
your dream you tell me
ultimately i mean for for customer
service based as far as
designing re-engineering different parts
and things that they need made i mean
most machine shops hire an engineer
okay but i mean ultimately it comes down
to whether i want to shoot
shoot for the stars and just bet on me
doing that or
going to college sort of a safer route
to just make a higher income
as an employee wait a second wait a
second
so you know this is this is ao i'm
getting all fired up
you have been taught connor the culture
has taught you that going to college is
a safer route
let me remind you you're already in the
industry
all you got to do is t keep doing a good
job and acquire some skills in the
actual shop and you can keep moving up
is that true or false and i don't mind
if i'm wrong tell me if i'm wrong
i'd say it's true absolutely it's true
so so again your income is based
on your output not
the degree am i right or am i wrong in
this particular business
so if you want to go get a mechanical
engineering degree just because you want
to have it
great but wait until you and your bride
pay off that debt
and you save up money and my friend here
can take over and tell you how to do
do the degree debt-free he'll give you
his book i'm just volunteering you to
give this young man in the book
but here's the point connor that's up to
you
but i'm answering your question do you
need to go to college
i don't think so i think you answered it
yeah uh do you want to
if you want to great but you better cash
flow it ao yeah i mean i agree with you
ken i really don't even want to talk
about college
i think that i think connor what you
need to do is just
focus on your sweet spot like what you
and ken just talked about
uh and maybe go to trade school so you
can learn some particular stuff around
that
but i would not go to college man i mean
i can i can give you a copy of my book
no i'm not gonna give you a copy of my
book what i want you to do is connect
with ken i want you to listen to his
show
um and i really want you to learn more
and more and more about his content
because i think your path is different
and there's nothing wrong with your path
being different yeah and i think you
just have to accept that
uh making forty five thousand dollars
right now if i'm not mistaken that's
that's what he said right yeah the
average
single person is making forty eight
thousand so you're only three thousand
dollars less than the average
person in america right now so you're
doing very well yes
and you and your wife double income pay
off the debt
walk out the baby steps pay off the debt
get the three to six months expenses in
the bank
start saving 15 of your income towards
retirement you guys are going to be net
worth millionaires starting as early as
you are
and then listen you're being trained
you're being paid right now
to learn how to run the business you
eventually want to run absolutely
absolutely
nick is with us in atlanta georgia uh
where the nba all-star
yeah was man that was last night last
night yeah nick how's it going man
how you guys doing doing good how about
yourself how can we help
doing good um so long story short i'm
turning 20 on wednesday i'm getting
married in july
congrats my fiance is going to be 26 in
july and
we're going to be projected to get onto
baby step 4
by year's end i would say great um
but my question for you is it's more
career career-based i'm a full-time
teacher
i've been teaching for five years now
and um
this year i've been really thinking
about long-term in terms of if i want to
take the administrational forward and
get into
principal superintendent things of that
nature
i'm going to have my student loans paid
off very soon but i do know that if i
do take this route i'll probably need
more schooling
so i just want to get your thoughts if
if you think um
you know like what your thoughts are
with that well the question is do you
want to be in
educational leadership yes or no
i i think i think i do because i didn't
really think about putting myself in
this position when i first started
teaching
but i've been as years have gone on i've
taken more leadership roles as a teacher
and
now when you say now nick i'm a words
guy
because usually words matter and i'm
just curious when you say i think i want
to
is that because you're still not 100
sure are you 80
sure are you 50 sure i want to know a
real accurate answer how sure are you
that you want to be
in administration in education
i'd say it's a little over 50 i mean i
wanted to be a teacher since i was like
a fifth grader right
it's my passion and i love it um but i
also i'm thinking just long term and
um right now i'm making 54 000 and i i
do
not for the number but i would like to
get in the pre-figure range just to
support my my family okay so here's the
deal
all right nick this is a potential trap
i get this call all the time on the ken
coleman show
ken i took a promotion ken i changed
careers
to make more money i'm six months in i'm
a year and a half in i'm three years in
i'm not happy
so nick you're 50 sure you have got to
practice the proximity principle right
now
and that says in order to do what nick
wants to do or think
he wants to do he's got to be around
people that are doing it in places where
it's happening here's my homework
assignment
you need to get on the phone or in
person with two to three people that are
in administration
in education and you do like a college
term paper on them over coffee or lunch
or over the phone
and when they fill in everything that
has to be done to get there
what it looks like during the day a week
a month a year several years
your head and heart are going to get
aligned when the head gets the knowledge
the heart will then confirm
or deny the idea you need to be 100
sure not 50. and don't pursue this just
for money
i'm gonna tell you right now there are
plenty of teachers out there that are
net worth millionaires chris hogan's
everyday millionaire study proves it
absolutely absolutely this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two
five five two two five we have uh this
segment and one more segment so we would
love
to take your phone calls uh ken coleman
your career expert and myself anthony
o'neil
life and money guy is here to help you
out people love to have a conversation
with you so
give us a call and we'll help you out as
much as we can
before we get to the phones you need to
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal rules and restrictions
apply so ken today's question comes from
tamara in connecticut she says my
daughter wants to go to school in south
carolina
for forty thousand dollars a year there
is a school here in connecticut
that has been that she has been accepted
to as well
and the cost is approximately 20 000
a year okay how do i get through to my
daughter that taking out
loans to go to school is not a good idea
i have told her that we can pay for her
to go local without her taking loans
but she insists on going to this school
that is double she didn't put that in
there i said that
um i have shown her uh the interest
calculator and she
doesn't care do you have any tips on how
to get
through to her yeah i have a tip
tell her i was waiting on that one
i just had to say i had to say it in a
respectful way tell her
your 18 year old daughter is not old
enough to make wise decisions
especially financial decisions uh right
now
you're going to tell your daughter hey
listen you're going to go to a school
that we can afford
because you can't afford nothing we are
not
signing we are not taking out any
student loans
especially when you can get the degree
here for half the price
so right now there's really no
convincing
it's a daughter this is what we
me your your father and yourself
can afford and we are going to pay cash
for
this school so this is the school you
want to go to
now if you want to go to another local
in-state school we are more than welcome
to have that conversation
but what we're not going to do is pay 20
000
more to get the same education to get
the same degree
just at a different school because right
now your daughter is excited about going
to her school
that her friends may be going to or the
school that may have some good
fraternities or sororities or known for
good partying or
known for this no tell her your dream
school is a school we can graduate from
debt free and this is school you go into
and so for me that's how i'm having a
conversation now i'm not going to go
that aggressive
but i am going to say hey daughter no
that's off the top but here's why i'm
saying no
and i know you may not understand it
today but when you graduate high school
and when you walk into high school when
you graduate
college and you walk across that
straight stage and you have a debt
free degree and when you meet your peers
and they're saying man i'm
i'm in fifty thousand dollars with the
debt i'm in a hundred and twenty five
thousand worth of debt
i'm drowning in student loan debt i
gotta move back home you will then thank
me for saying no so that's just my
answer on that
am i wrong there can you have you have a
daughter no i think you're spot on she
has an assumption problem she's assuming
it's her decision
it's not she plays a role in the
decision but she doesn't have the final
say so yeah i'd have a little fun with
it i wouldn't even make it a big
discussion either to be sarcastic and go
have you lost your mind
um i'm in charge
and these are all the reasons why i'm in
charge i have some fun with it and just
take the oxygen out of it in my house i
mean when my kids think that when they
start making decisions and tell me
they're going to do stuff i go
well then we have a role problem let me
remind everybody of your role
in this house you know man that's what i
like to do hey man listen my parents
were
they weren't even like that i said mom i
want to do this she would just ignore me
like i never even said nothing right
yeah what well it's great that you want
to i'm glad that you want to hey there's
things i want to do as well
hey i want to drive a lamborghini every
day right
i'm unable to do that man listen me too
okay i can't afford that i can want to
do something all i want to but if i
can't afford it i'm not going to do it
yes so there you go pretty simple stuff
yeah pretty simple pretty simple
ike is in pensacola man hey good
afternoon how can ken and i help
hello can you hear me yes sir
hey uh i guess i have a question about
church oh yeah the pastor is in
anthony awaits your question good yeah
yeah i'm debt free
churchill 10 paid 10
times each month and have done for years
okay the church out here now do not give
us a feedback on where the money is
going
so am i supposed to be happy we're just
paying 10
and leaving it up to them to make
decisions on the money or should i know
where my money is going
am i being a good steward i mean
if you want to go biblical yes you give
10 because that's biblical so you're not
really giving it to the church you're
giving it to god
uh then the church is going to be
responsible to how they're dealing with
the funds
with god now if you know for sure
that the church is doing something
irresponsible they're not being good
stewardships of the money
then it's not even about giving money to
the church it's about leaving the church
period
okay so that's what i would say but if i
am at the church
i it's not my responsibility to question
how the church
is dealing with the funds my my personal
beliefs
and i want to make sure i'm being
careful here uh because
this is my personal conviction i'm not
giving money
to pastor ken per save he was the pastor
of my church
i'm being obedient and i'm just i'm just
setting myself up to receive blessings
from god
the church is not going to give me a
blessing the church is not going to
uh give me a miracle i'm i'm saying okay
god is saying give 10
because 10 back in his hands is much
better than in my hands
and so i'm activating faith i'm
activating god so he can know he can
trust me with more
now from there i it's between the church
and god how they deal with those funds
but if i publicly see and i know for
sure that they are
not being good stewards with the funds
then it's not about me giving tithes
i'm finding a completely different
church
and so yes if the church is still in
debt
if you do not know where the funds are
going
um you know i'm not really too concerned
i don't know where my funds are going
uh inside my personal church they do
have like a yearly
update on what they did the previous
year and how many mission trips and i
don't i don't even go to those meetings
because again i trust my church uh and
my church is still in debt
uh so to answer your question yes
wherever you're getting
fed at you should be sowing into the
church but if you feel as if the church
is doing something wrong
leave ken you want to ask something
today we've not added anything very good
such a good question man thank you so
much for calling in um on that one
ashley's with us in detroit good
afternoon absolutely
how can he help i'm sorry i hit the
wrong oh okay there we go
all right that was weird i hit four and
it went back okay hey ashley how can we
help
hey guys um i was wondering so i'm kind
of in the pickle
um i'm in the process of i want to buy a
house but i also want to go back to
school and get my degree
okay why do you want to get your degree
um right now i'm a cna and i just kind
of want to go back to just to get before
our
rn okay and how much schooling do you
need
is it two year program uh
well with my past credits and i would
have probably have to
redo more classes because it's been like
10 years since i've been in school
okay so um i would want to just start
fresh honestly
okay so how many years are we talking
about
about four years okay and are you going
to cash flow your way through it
i'm hoping to i don't want to do any
credit at all good
well i'm about you said hoping hoping
is still a possibility so uh we're not
even having a conversation going back to
school can unless we know for sure
absolutely
we're not going to borrow any money yes
no i don't
i've done the student loan thing paid it
off right now i'm about two thousand
dollars in credit card debt
and that's just only because of last
year you know through
co do the covet okay well
i want you to hold on uh because we're
about to come up on a break
and i want to make sure that ken and i
can definitely help you walk you through
this process because ken is
he's a career expert and i think your
question is important
but then also i want to hear about your
dreams about purchasing a home and
we need to figure out what's what's the
best move yep
going back to school or purchasing a
home so stay on the line
uh ashley and we'll be right back after
this uh commercial break all right
okay all right um yeah i like this
question this is good
there are some steps she needs to take
and i like that we're gonna kind of come
back and reset for her
help her figure out what do i do first
what does that mean
how long will it delay the house
purchase so good stuff all right
so when we come back we'll pick ashley
back
up he is anthony o'neil i'm ken coleman
and this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture and quote comes from
second corinthians chapter 5
verse 17 and we all with unveiled face
beholding the glory of the lord are
being transformed into the same
image from one degree of glory to
another
for this comes from the lord who is the
spirit coco chanel once said
don't spend time beating on a wall
hoping to transform it
into a door uh before break ken and i
were talking to
ashley out of detroit and she has an
amazing uh question that i think is very
important for us to dive
into and i didn't want to rush her off
the line
ken and i both didn't want to do that
because it's a hard decision do i go
back to school at 32
or do i go purchase a home so ashley
where what's your exact question for us
how can we best
help and serve you um right now
okay right now um i was just wondering
did i going back to school will
be a better like option for me i know
both are
pretty adamant to me right now but what
would be better
like i don't want to get into any more
debt i've
literally gotten out of debt i haven't
used
any debts in the last what five years
until
you know kobe hit but i just want to
know what will be better for me in this
situation
are you prepared to buy a house right
now do you have the the uh at least 20
down payment no i don't have the 20 down
payment so
i have the 10 so it's like depending on
right now my range will be between 80
and 100
000. so i do have that 10 percent to put
down
but i don't know like what am i making
the right decision when it comes towards
this because i do have kids too
but i also kind of want to just kind of
further my career and i don't want to
like
be in one of those dead-end careers
where you're just actually just stuck in
how much are you making right now ashley
annually a year
i make about 40 000. yeah and then if
you go to rn i think you'll be making
right at about 80 to 100.
yeah okay um
can you cashflow this go ahead well yeah
answer that quick can you cash flow your
way we were talking about this before
but you feel like you can cash your
cash flow your way through nursing
school
no not really not if i use what i have
because my savings is pretty much the
same ten percent of
that it was yeah so you have ten
thousand dollars pretty much in your
savings right
pretty much how much is it for your
product
eight okay how much how much would the
program cost you um it depends because i
kind of wanted to
like start fresh and go through
community college before i actually get
into the program
yeah um it's gonna be about 40 grand on
average
yeah yeah well look
ashley i mean you get to decide i mean
and and i think he and i are probably on
the same page here i
i mean look um
you're you are pretty much capped out
financially in the current field that
you're
in uh you could you could work a second
job to help cash flow your way through
and save but you got kids i mean that's
there's a lot of sacrifice ahead for you
regardless
so whether you choose buy the house
first and then eventually go
to nursing school their sacrifice if you
choose i'm going to rent
and i'm going to go to nursery school
and put off buying a house down the road
there's a sacrifice there so there's no
getting out of you decide
of you sacrificing something and and
then to
to save up more money to put down on a
home to save up the money to cash flow
through nursing school
either way you're gonna have to really
uh get after it and you're gonna have to
sacrifice say no to some things you're
gonna have to work really really hard
and and in my opinion uh
based on what i do every day talking to
men and women who are trying to figure
out what they want to do with their life
i think you
really really want to be an rn uh not
just because of the money but because of
the work itself i think it's really
important to you so
based on what i'm hearing you say and
you can correct this
but what i'm hearing you say is that
that
really matters to you and so i would put
off buying a house there will always be
houses
and i know that some people look at well
i'm 32 i don't own a home yet
i just wouldn't allow that narrative to
hit to kind of hit you in the head every
day like you're some sort of
less than because you don't own a home
yet i mean your reality is your reality
yeah and to make the future better
i think a big part of that is cash
flowing your way through nursing school
so i would not spend any money on a home
right now
yeah and i just did the i just did the
research for you so i want to make sure
my numbers are right so yeah on the low
end is going to be about 40
000 up to 100 000 to get that degree so
you will go
definitely to the low end yes uh to get
that degree
but here's the thing rns are starting
off on zip recruiter
starting off at about 50 000 to about 94
000 a year so i think the question is
going to be like hey
you got to look up in your particular
city okay what are rn's making if
they're only making 50
000 a year 54 000 a year and you're
already making 45
is it worth it and then am i willing to
move to make more money yeah
so right now i think you have to really
step back and ask yourself ashley okay
let me do all the research this is what
i want to do uh like what ken teaches
what i teach and then figure out okay
what's
what can i make and then scale
not scale but do once you do the proper
research
put them side by side what's the best
move for me
and my family here's the other thing
ashley you said something twice
you said i really want to start from
scratch well you know
i want to do a lot of things but i just
don't think
you know what i'm saying like i don't
think you need to do that you don't need
to do that
don't do that like that's some sort of
honorable thing
you're you're an awesome rock star okay
ashley i'm not picking on you what i'm
saying is
that's a purist and i appreciate that as
much as anybody
but i'm just telling you don't start
from scratch just because you want to if
you've already got credits
let's start where we left off that's
going to save you time and money
ashley time and money man thank you so
much absolutely for calling in
you got this don't quit don't quit you
got this
adam is with us in chicago illinois good
afternoon adam how can ken and i help
hey guys uh i'm calling in i got kind of
myself into a financial situation
so i'm just about to finish med school
and before this i worked really hard i
got out of undergrad with no debt
okay there we go with med school i i
couldn't
you know blame that and right now i got
uh 420 993 in med school that
i have 420 you wish
420 thousand hundred thousand yeah i i
wish
wow you graduated with your bachelor's
with no
no no debt now he's in 420 000 in med
school debt
okay how much do you make a year right
now adam he's not out yet
zero i'm i'm graduating right now
how much do you think you will make a
year
uh an intern depending on you know where
you're working exactly can be anywhere
between 52 to 60k
oh my goodness and what's the eventual
goal
eventual destination the invent
eventual destination is interventional
radiology
which is going to pay what range very
well
depending on you know where you work and
the type of practice you're in
anywhere between 350 to 8.
cool okay so what's your question we
only got about a minute and a half
okay so my question for you guys is i
know that the
public service loan forgiveness those
guys are not getting their loans
you know forgiven it's only like one
percent uh
i ran the numbers and with what i'm
taking home
if i'm able to you know tutor
a little bit throughout the week i can
augment that enough to where i'll
barely be able to make the payments to
pay
you know this off theoretically in 10
years with the
with the graduated plan would you guys
suggest that over you know making the
bare minimum
uh loan payments that i see you know so
many of my
colleagues make and then you know it's
20 years post-med school and they're
still you know paying this thing off
adam how old are you man
10 30. all right cool great here here's
the thing adam you're going to be 30 for
the rest of
him for the next 10 15 years you're
going to work like you're 30
you're going to live like you're 30 for
the next 10 years you do not have time
for luxury you do not have time for
um fun you're in 420
000 worth of debt right now yes you're
gonna work your behind
off you're gonna make extra payments if
your girlfriend comes
up to you and says hey baby can we go
out to eat you're going to tell her no
we can have peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches
at the house you're not getting a nice
car you're going to get an
ugly car you're going to get a car that
you could pay for cash i'm sorry
but that's what you got to do i'm sorry
ken thank you so much
james james kelly thank you all so much
america thank you so much
don't forget the caliber of our
financial future will be determined by
the decisions we made today
you made the right one by listening to
the ramsay show with ken coleman and
myself
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you